achtung schocker aber jeder welt als
filme die nur jemals gesehen hast wurde
gefragt ob interstellar der marsianer
oder apollo 13 green screen kabel
parabelflüge sollte eigentlich keinen
überraschen aber weder tom hanks noch
matthew mcconaughey noch mit damon waren
jemals im weltall geschweige denn auf
dem mars oder in einem schwarzen loch
doch genau das soll sich jetzt ändern
wie sollte es anders sein aber niemand
geringeres als tom cruise will ins
weltall der umstrittene schauspieler der
sich seit jahrzehnten damit einen namen
macht dass er alle noch so verrückten
stunts selber aus führt der will nun den
ersten film produzieren der auch
wirklich im weltall gedreht wurde und
zwar ohne green screen und ohne
irgendwelche kamera tricks da gibt es
nur ein problem
jemand ist ihnen zuvorgekommen
ganz kurz falls ihr es noch nicht
mitbekommen habt wir haben dieses t
shirt hier die sein um das james webb
teleskop zu feiern und ihr könnt es
haben allerdings nur noch bis ende
august dann schließen wir die bestellung
alternativ könnt ihr unterstützer auf
page e on werden und so ein shirt hier
in eurer größe gewinnen oder sogar
garantiert als belohnung zugeschickt
bekommen wenn ihr den richtigen run habt
alle infos dazu findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung und jetzt geht es los
mit dem video
am 5 mai 2020 hatte die nasa angekündigt
dass sie mit tom cruise zusammenarbeiten
wollen um den ersten film im weltall zu
drehen das action adventure soll
zumindest in teilen auf der
internationalen raumstation und auch in
der rakete auf dem weg dorthin gedreht
werden inhaltlich ist noch nicht so viel
bekannt außer dass natürlich tom cruise
die hauptrolle spielen soll und
überraschung für eine hollywood story ja
der einzige mensch ist der die erde noch
retten kann
aber nicht nur vom cruise soll zwei ss
fliegen auch doug liman der regisseur
kommt mit dieser hat dann an bord die
aufgabe die kamera zu führen das licht
zu setzen den ton im auge zu behalten
und sogar das make-up zu machen
befördert werden sollen sie auf einer
extrem space mission mit einer crew
dragon -kapsel von space exile macht
freut sich auch schon auf den film
anscheinend wurde das projekt an
universe studios geputscht und zwar in
einem zoom call und ohne drehbuchentwurf
aber anscheinend reicht es wenn man tom
cruise heißt und ins weltall will um
auch genau das zu bekommen
universal hat wohl an ort und stelle 200
millionen dollar zugesagt was das
projekt zu einem der teuersten filme
aller zeiten machen würde dabei reicht
das vermutlich gar nicht denn ein sitzt
alleine kostet in der space extra dragon
-kapsel so um die 55 millionen us dollar
macht für regisseur und schauspieler
zusammen 110 dann will die nasa für
private astronauten auch noch eine extra
gebühr denn die benutzten ja bei ihrem
aufenthalt die einrichtungen der asf und
dann muss man doch mit einrechnen dass
tom cruise der bestbezahlte schauspieler
hollywoods ist für top gun maverick hat
er angeblich über 100 millionen dollar
bekommen vielleicht auch gerechtfertigt
denn er macht ja bekannt nicht alle
seiner stunts selber kampfjets fliegen
das höchste gebäude der welt erklimmen
an flugzeugen hängen und aus flugzeugen
herausspringen letzteres übrigens 106 x
und ausfüllen aus denen man wirklich
sauerstoffmasken braucht wobei in meinen
augen so viele stunts machen kann wie er
will tom cruise ist auch bekennender
scientologe und die zehntausenden
menschen das geld aus der tasche dafür
sollte man ihn auf jeden fall
kritisieren aber es sollte sowieso alles
nicht so kommen wie geplant statt im
oktober 2021 mit spacex zu heiß es zu
fliegen wurden die dreharbeiten
verschoben anscheinend aus
versicherungstechnischen gründen an
denen man aber arbeite kann ich auch
verstehen tom cruise im weltall zu
versichert ist wahrscheinlich relativ
teuer gut der erste film im weltall kann
warten oder doch nicht genau im selben
monat oktober 2021 startete roskosmos
ein verblüffend ähnliches projekt
an bord der sms 19 flogen die
schauspielerin julia basiert und der
regisseur klinische penker zwölf tage
lang schossen sie auf der
internationalen raumstation den film the
challenge in der eine ärztin unter
zeitdruck auf die iss geschickt wird um
das leben eines kosmonauten zu retten
sie soll dort in der schwerelosigkeit
eine herz-op durchführen auch hier
machte der regisseur wohl alles kamera
licht ton und make-up zwei echte
kosmonauten der russen sollen wohl aber
auch bei den dreharbeiten geholfen haben
so dass die crew immerhin zu viert war
der erste film im weltall das ich nicht
lache jedes doktor watson video das ich
jemals gesehen habe wurde im weltall
gedreht ja genau ich bin der erste space
youtube-kanal aller zeiten ich das in
der mikrogravitation hinbekommen habe
nun ich lasse mich bei meinem team an
den boden kleben ist doch klar und warum
meine haare dabei nicht umher wen 0 habt
ihr schon mal gefragt habe ich immer so
viel styling in den haaren habe drei
kilogramm wachsen jeden tag das ist ein
aufwand sage ich euch sehe ich die
videos auf die server der erde hochladen
mit jpn natürlich damit kann ich von
überall auf der welt so tun als wäre ich
in einem von bis zu 60 länder ein klick
und schon bin ich wieder auf der erde
dann kann das normale internet sehen
mega schnell sogar das ist ziemlich
praktisch beim space verbunden wie mit
ich kann damit auch auf das internet aus
anderen ländern zu greifen hört sich ja
auch so ist immerhin die internationale
raumstation hier das ganze kostet mich
nur zwei euro 88 pro monat viel weniger
als mein haar weiß es gibt eine 30 tage
geld zurück garantie und wenn ich dabei
den coach auf dauer zu nutze dann kriegt
ist sogar für ganze monate geschenkt und
jetzt lasse ich mich ja festkleben denn
gleich gehts weiter mit dem video
das projekt der russen ist also
erstaunlich nah am projekt der
amerikaner dran irgendwie lässt mich
hier das gefühl nicht los dass man
einfach ein space race gewinnen wollte
das passt auch mit den aussagen des
chefs von roskosmos zusammen der von
drei bis vier monaten vorbereitung
sprach und auch dass das filmprojekt
erstmals im mai 2021 angekündigt wurde
ein jahr nach der ankündigung der nasa
was die amis machen den ersten film im
weltall der mord schnell wir machen auch
einen film am besten im selben monat und
dann schneiden wir denn einfach
schneller h
zusätzliches glück dass die amerikaner
ihr projekt dann sowieso verschoben
haben mehr aufmerksamkeit wird tom
cruise mit seinem film zwar vermutlich
schon bekommen aber der erste
professionell im weltall gedrehte
feature film in der geschichte der
menschheit ist russisch passt ravagli
aber warten wieso ist das so merkwürdig
formuliert professionell feature nun
wird challenge ist tatsächlich nicht der
erste film der im weltall gedreht wurde
auch wenn das oft behauptet wird schon
1984 wurde waschen kochen beziehen quasi
rückkehr aus dem orbit rausgebracht auch
von den russen der film wurde teilweise
auf der sowjetischen raumstation style
gut 7 und dem raumschiff sojus gedreht
und zwar nicht von professionellen
filmemachern sondern von den kosmonauten
selber und der erste film der komplett
im weltall gedreht wurde also keine
szenen auf der erde beinhaltet der geht
wiederum nach england apple ios 4 kann
2012 raus und ist einen acht minuten
langen kurzfilm vom briten richard
garriott in dem vier astro und
kosmonauten auf der iss mitspielen er
ist wohl nicht besonders gut dafür aber
sehr demokratisch gemacht da allen
teammitgliedern auf der ice erst
angeboten wurde mitzumachen und dass
jeder dieselbe menge an screentime
bekommt produziert und geschnitten wurde
der film aber in den usa deswegen würde
ich den punkt jetzt er den amerikanern
geben wenn wir hier schon das film space
race bewerten wollen deswegen ist der
challenge also nur der erste feature
film also lange spielfilm der
professionell im weltall gedreht wurde
herauskommen soll noch dieses jahr und
ich bin mal gespannt wie er wird der
regisseur hat wohl schon 2017 einen
space film gemacht dem natürlich noch
auf der erde und zwar über saljut 7 die
raumstation auf der allererste space
film gedreht wurde und sein film hat
richtig gute kritiken bekommen
[Musik]
ok die russen haben also das film space
race gewonnen aber wie schon beim echten
space race hat das einiges an ressourcen
gekostet und das hat nicht allen
gefallen während der chef von roskosmos
den film als experiment gesehen hat ob
man zwei normale menschen in drei bis
vier monaten auf einen weltraumflug
vorbereiten kann gab es von anderer
seite kritik immerhin hat man ja hier
zwei zivilisten ins all geschossen und
dafür zwei kosmonauten von der liste
gestrichen die jahrelang darauf
vorbereitet wurden auf der iss
experimente für die wissenschaft
durchzuführen das wäre ein missbrauch
von öffentlichen geldern manche sagen
sogar dass es illegal wäre die
raumstation führt nicht
wissenschaftliche zwecke zu nutzen
ein großer kritiker war es ja egal ob
der schulleiter von roskosmos selber und
dieser wurde daraufhin berichten zufolge
gefeuert als aber eine menge kosmonauten
sowohl im ruhestand als auch noch aktive
dagegen protestierten wurde dieser
wieder eingestellt was jetzt aus der
internationalen raumstation wird und ob
es einen nachfolger gibt das ist ein
thema für ein eigenes video und wenn ihr
das sehen wollt dann schreibt uns das
gerne mal unten in die kommentare wenn
wir hier sehen dass dafür genug
interesse da ist dann machen wir gerne
ein video über die zukunft der iss und
was ist mit der zukunft von filmen im
weltall nun die firma space
entertainment enterprises
behauptet beim tom cruise weltall film
mitzuwirken
und sie haben im januar diesen jahres
angekündigt zusammen mit ex im space ein
modul für die iss zu bauen das quasi ein
filmstudio im weltall werden soll dieses
soll im dezember 2024 an die iss
angedockt werden und achtung das soll
aufblasbar sein die sp serena will ein
produktionsstudio für filmdrehs
live-fernsehen serien specials und sogar
konzerte sein und dabei vor allem das
nutzen was man sonst nirgendwo auf der
erde hat nämlich mikrogravitation auch
sportveranstaltungen werden auf der
website versprochen wobei ich mich frage
wie man in einer kugel mit gerade mal
sechs metern durchmesser sport treiben
will außer vielleicht mal spielt space 2
ich bin mal gespannt ob daraus was wird
zum einen weil vieles in diesem bereich
schon durch deutlich günstigere
parabelflügen möglich ist können wir zum
beispiel dieses musikvideo hier und zum
anderen weil die ice es wie gesagt ab
2024 einen ihrer grössten partner
verliert die zukunft ist also ungewiss
was aber nicht ungewiss ist dass ihr
diese t-shirts ihr jetzt noch bestellen
könnten dafür nur noch bis zum 31 august
zeit danach ist schluss und bis mittwoch
dem 24 august könnt ihr noch
unterstützer auf kathrin werden und mit
etwas glück 1 von 5 t shirts gewinnen
oder i will den rang des professors oder
höher aus und bekommt garantiert ein t
shirt von uns zugeschickt wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
post the hobbit